thank you
[Music]
yo the uh someone just set the record
for the longest consecutive spaghetti
90 inches he made yeah spaghetti it's
[ __ ] sick check it out dude who is it
get the [ __ ] out of here dude why are
you saying that the Guinness Book of
World Records is such a [ __ ] sham
where's the meteor dude I'm ready
send it 90 inches of one continuous
spaghetti that's 90 inches is the pasta
handmade no they found it you have to do
they find her they make that huh
yeah look it's handmade dude there's no
there's no scale it's gonna be the
smallest [ __ ] noodles look at the
lane you know what a spaghetti all right
that is not a spaghetti you should put a
spoon next to it or something that store
that store-bought pasta some kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] parasite that's Paris
dude it's funny guys can we just be
happy how come there's no marinery on it
yeah there it is a little bit right
there about to give them some other
information
yeah Ryan's going to be like yeah this
just came out of a urethra yeah exactly
this is a worm no that's medical [ __ ]
napkin this came out of so much
dude Ryan were you part of the 1996
Olympic uh gymnastics team because that
jacket is [ __ ] fired
[Laughter]
I don't know I just noticed it right now
I was like okay all of you [ __ ]
spaghetti caters all right I was just
testing you it's not spaghetti this is a
handle-less jump rope that a man was
able to stuff completely as you read
through it oh that's what the red is
it's a jump rope so I need to [ __ ]
buy a lotto ticket today it's a did you
call that yes wait you said it was a
jump roll no I just said it came out of
a urethra yep good call so a 79 year old
man took the handles off of a jump rope
stuffed the entire 90 inches of jump
rope into his ear wait a 70. it got
stuck in his bladder they had to cut his
bladder open kids you gotta quit the
porn now you gotta quit now what does
this keep happening this guy's like I
can't even nut unless I removed okay
I used to I'm gonna shove it in my car
bro what's the appeal of shoving things
in urethra is there is there something
because that's a king it's been
happening a lot why don't you find out
I'm so lucky that I don't have any kinks
like this I thank God every day thank
God everything I think a lot but one day
I think I'm gonna be afraid that it does
happen yeah you think one day it'll just
be out of anybody here it'll be me yeah
that's you bro how's your urethra size
is it it's pretty tight yeah I think by
default most of us are pretty narrow
urethras I guess due to jump rope handle
a jump rope handle that's rough all 90
speaking of which hang on did a doctor
[ __ ] pull it out and whip it and just
started still good that's still good and
the nurses come in like yeah
my [ __ ] blood's all flying everywhere
oh there you go that's what it looked
like when it was in there so what
happened is once he got all 90 inches of
the rope in and it was just chilling
inside of his bladder after you urinate
your bladder contracts or something oh
no way so then it started to do that
magical thing like when uh airpod wires
get tangled in your pocket and it
tangled the Rope up so you couldn't be
magical they should have just left it
there how carefully I put it in my
pocket it always comes out so now we
know the same is true for jump ropes
inside of a bladder that is good to know
actually that is used look pretty
healthy
yeah for 79 not bad good too look at it
yeah it's lighten up pretty good that
goes to show that no matter what
even at senior age men are still boys oh
yeah dude yeah because we've covered
stories with jump ropes yeah we've
coached cover stories of kids doing this
of teens of adults and now Jerry that's
right but a jump rope is thick rope has
got to be a record but then you could
stretch it out over the it could have
just been yarn when he was young and as
he Grew Older he's like now it's jump
rope his old timer getting looser and
looser with that age you know they're
bigger and then he's looking over at the
next jump rope which is that one with
the beads on it yeah
like look how much blood is on that
thing it does look like the longest
spaghetti
you had me fooled for a sec you got a
little hungry too licking my lips
spaghetti because now I can like just
[Music]
after they cut his bladder open and they
just took the whole thing out he made a
full recovery no complications guys
doctors like I don't know I thought it
was I I thought I was eating spaghetti
and it was a jump rope did he try to do
some [ __ ] they didn't even I don't
believe they even tried to get a story
out of it the man did not explain why
you know you know when they have like uh
well they have like like murders or
something like the sheriff will going
like on the state and on the news you
have like a press conference I think
they should do that for stories like
yeah where some guy has this conference
for this I think so you gotta own up you
gotta this is a PSA for the for everyone
else the cops takes his Podium he's like
ladies and gentlemen we got him
and he steps up he explains them share
with him that little factoid you just
read it's a Japanese guy so you know his
Yuri throw a small oh you're right and
who's
Ruth was again makes sense the Congolese
thank you so he has a lot of stress
right now yeah yeah I've seen those
stats you know what as soon as you said
Japanese it made sense a 70 year old man
would do this why he's 79.
they're just
perverted are they dude my grandpa used
to kiss my wife on the lips it was weird
what a pervert Yeah it's [ __ ] weird
do you ever get mad nah it's like he's
gonna get a little moment of whatever
but Jesus Christ is so did he did he add
a little tongue
nah he would just do like the thing but
it was like Jesus did Nikki ever comment
on it oh we talked about it the whole
time what would you say she was laughing
about it she's like yeah your grandpa
like really likes me oh my God he knows
did we have to kiss her on the top left
or just the bottom what was that did he
ever kiss her on the lip Center what are
you saying about my wife
she has respect for elders no it was it
was
it was plead kiss it was like a a full
both lips and I was like [ __ ] I was like
all right old man all right you gotta
get yourself to be willing to do that
too but she's partly responsible for
that you think so yeah what was she
wearing did she pull my wife aside
tonight
put a jump rope in your grandpa's dick
teach him a lesson I would but he's dead
makes it easier yeah yeah so Japanese
guys huh that's a thing my stepdad's an
old pervert he wants to go to the May
cafes all the [ __ ] time and my niece
was like yeah he wanted to go thinking
that I would love to go and I'm into
this [ __ ] she goes I don't [ __ ] like
this [ __ ] but he kept begging so I went
and she goes it was weird can you
describe maid Cafe what happens it's
like you know when there are a bunch of
girls dressed up in high school girls
dressed up in made outfits and [ __ ] High
School
cafe food and then it's all it's all
weird in there that's so weird it's kind
of mixed and the niece is like the same
age
yep basically
and she was all like he he kept using me
as an excuse but I knew he wanted to go
I have to say high school girls are not
what they used to be when I was growing
up when I was in high school I was like
going to get a haircut recently in Vegas
I got stuck by the [ __ ] high school
and all these kids were goddamn walking
across the street being little transient
[ __ ] like not using the lights not
waiting just [ __ ] running across the
street constantly if you can't move and
everyone's like so pissed in traffic and
just seeing them they look like little I
I can't imagine how I was ever attracted
to high school girls yeah because they
just look like little kids yeah yeah
they're kids but but no
they were hot when I was growing up yeah
like clueless now they look whack you
gotta go to those main cafes I guess I
guess now they look whack yeah dude they
were so hot when I was growing up
whack when I was growing up the
description they're different I like
older women when I was in high school I
wanted college girls
oh well yeah what was the oldest woman
you were with when you were young when I
was I was thinking 18 or 19 I was with a
23 year old and we lived together she
was an older woman lived together she
was old yeah nice okay we live together
was it a 10 out of 10. would you would
you recommend dating an older woman
neither geriatric yeah
I don't know I just in my head they
looked
more womanly because you're an 18. yeah
and then if you're if you're going 16
they look like kids but then if you're
like if they're like 20s they look like
women just in my head at least when I
saw a picture of myself when I was 18 I
was like I look like a 14 year old boy
yeah there's no way the the thing that I
did is
I remember when I was in kindergarten in
first grade I got my first yearbook and
I remember looking at the eighth graders
and they looked like grown ass adults
that you would see in like movies yeah
and I was like really holy [ __ ] and then
I looked back and found the same
yearbook and I looked at those same
eighth graders and they still look like
adults because I think what it is it's
the style at the time it's the hair
styles it's how they have their makeup
it's eating fit mustaches yeah stick
mustache that's exactly what this thing
this I was watching this video it said
that like the reason why old people
still look old when they're young is the
style it's yeah it's because you
associate psychologically that fashion
with old right yeah yeah it's like
nurses who graduated in certain years
they have the like little cap with the
Beehive haircut yeah it's like it always
stays that era it's like kind of weird
but now I don't know what these kids are
going to look like later they look like
they'll be kids forever I mean they just
look like what we did in junior high
like the same style is back a lot of the
same throwback [ __ ] they just look like
they're going raving
yeah well that and a lot of Pokemon
trainers for some reason yeah a lot of
[ __ ] small backpacks so what's what's
the verdict Colleen uh thick urethra Hot
or Not
come on don't make that face you're
being judged
yeah I'm just so impressed that Anthony
guessed it
hey Anthony knows how things work around
here this has been happening a lot he's
got a Powerball he's got to get a
Powerball
I think this is like honestly this is
like the fourth urethra stuffing this
year wow dude there's so many I'm sure I
heard that that's one of the biggest
things of emergency rooms is people
stuffing [ __ ] in holes in their body
from their [ __ ] [ __ ] dick [ __ ]
remember when I [ __ ] Nikki into a
nightstand yup went to the emergency
room when we were alone in Vegas wait
what happened you [ __ ] her so hard he
hit her in the head and they had to go
to the hospital I was spinning that
[ __ ] around and like she smacked her
head on uh on like in the hotel like on
this like nightstand thing yeah and I
was like oh [ __ ] and then she's bleeding
all over the place it was wild the
opening plot to Fugitive
I don't think she would have mined it
honestly but the the blood is what
stopped there yeah yeah there's so much
blood that I was like whoa what the [ __ ]
past the point it's not hot anyway
brings it huh then he just turns off the
light
wow I was just I had long fingernails